[موسيقى]
لكن ذكرتي قبل الفاصل ست رغد انه كان
يستمع الى ما تقولين وهذا كان قرار مصير
يعني ان تذهبوا الى الاردن عام 95 واهلا
انشقاقه هناك الم يستشرك في هذه الخطوه
وماذا قلت له وقتها
في خطوه الخروج استشارني
وكنت شاعره اذا بقيت راح يصير حمام دم
حمام الدم اللي يصير ما راح يصير بين
اشخاص غريبه علي ما اعرفها
هم اهلي بالدرجه الاولى والدك وزوجك وزوجي
زوجي ويعني واولادي
فدرءا لهذه الفتنه
ايتها باتخاذ القرار في مغادره الوطن
مو من السهل علي اني بنت رئيس دوله وبنت
صدام حسين مو سهل علي اروح لاي بلد اخر مع
العلم انه كان استقبالنا بالاردن رائع وما
شعروني بالغربه ولا
[موسيقى]
لكن في الشق الاخر
في المؤتمر اللي صار والاعلان اللي انطرح
بالطريقه المعروفه لا لم اكن اعلم لم
تكوني تعلمين ماذا سيقول حسين كامل في
المؤتمر الصحفي في عمان عام 95
[موسيقى]